los franceses comienzan a ver la luz al
final del túnel de este tercer
confinamiento después de haber escuchado
esta noche de los anuncios que el
presidente emmanuel macrón hizo a la
prensa regional para detallar su plan
progresivo de confinamiento de este país
en cuatro etapas la primera de ellas
comienza el próximo lunes cuando se
vuelven a autorizar los viajes entre
regiones la segunda etapa está fijada
para el 19 de mayo ese día se retrasa en
dos horas el inicio del toque de queda
de las siete a las nueve de la noche por
lo que es más importante abre nuevamente
bares y restaurantes en terraza y
también los sitios culturales incluso
los cines los sitios que acogen
actividades deportivas y los comercios
siempre con un aforo limitado la tercera
etapa está fijada para el 9 de junio a
partir de ese día abren bares y
restaurantes en sala se atrasa
nuevamente en dos horas el toque de
queda a las once de la noche y lo que es
más importante se pone en práctica el
paseo sanitario ese certificado donde se
sabe si tenemos o no las vacunas contra
el cob y ya hemos tenido la enfermedad
después de más de 15 días si tenemos un
psr negativo será importante pues con
ese certificado se podrá asistir a
partir de esas
a eventos de más de 5000 personas y
finalmente la última etapa es el 30 de
junio a partir de ese día ya no habrá
más toques de queda pero ojo el
presidente no dijo nada sobre las
discotecas que siguen cerradas dice que
sigue privilegiando el trabajo a
distancia y también siguen siendo
obligatorios los gestos barrera pero
este calendario depende de un dato la
cifra de incidencia del cob y 19 esto es
el número de casos por cada 100.000
habitantes si los datos no son buenos
este calendario no se mantiene